before we get started we should say
happy birthday to us on CBS this morning
it is our one two three four five six
seven eight
birthday perceive it four eight yeah for
CBS this morning and welcome to CBS this
morning we begin with this
no birthday talk this is all very
serious news today Iranian media
reporting new high-level talk of harsher
revenge after President Trump dismissed
Iran's missile attacks on US troops in
Iraq the president indicated yesterday
that he plans no military response in a
statement intended to lower tensions in
the region to the people and leaders of
Iran we want you to have a future and a
great future one that you deserve one of
prosperity at home and harmony with the
nations of the world the United States
is ready to embrace peace with all who
seek it in Washington House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi plans a vote today on a
move by Democrats to block the president
from taking military action against Iran
on his own and two Republican senators
are complaining bitterly you could say
over the administration's efforts to
justify the attack that killed pay top
Iranian general last week Paula Reed is
at the White House for us Paul oh good
morning rare to hear a Republican
senator rebuked the president this way
why are they so angry rare indeed good
morning Tony well yesterday these
lawmakers met with top administration
officials to discuss the
administration's justification for these
strikes and it did not go well
one of the president's close Republican
allies emerge from this meeting and
called the discussion quote insane and
said that it had prompted him to now
align with Democrats to limit the
president's war powers and today the
White House is under fire for what
critics call a lack of transparency
about its strategy in Iran I believe we
are safer today than before president
Trump ordered our military to take out
Qasem Soleimani in last night's
interview on the CBS Evening News with
Norah O'Donnell vice president Mike
Pence showed no regrets over the killing
of irani and Jen
Kusum Soleimani what the President did
was restore the credibility of our
military deterrence but after
administration officials briefed
lawmakers on Iran Wednesday one ardent
supporter of President Trump emerged
from the meeting furious with the
administration's approach was probably
the worst briefing I've seen at least on
a military issue in the nine years I've
served in the United States Senate Utah
Republican Senator Mike Lee said
officials tried to quash any debate over
the strike one of the messages we
received from the briefers was do not
debate do not discuss the issue of the
appropriateness of further millar
military intervention against Iran
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo who was
one of the officials briefing lawmakers
did not take questions from reporters
after the meeting mr. secretary
secretary don't feel super that's what
they did to us as well but after
returning to the Pentagon last night
defense secretary Mark Esper defended
the administration's efforts off-camera
a very good discussion robust discussion
Lee says the briefing convinced him that
he should support a resolution by
Democrat Tim Kaine that would limit the
administration's ability to take further
military action against Iran without
congressional approval but that may not
have too much of an impact on the
president speaking from the White House
Wednesday he signaled that for now he
will respond to Iran with sanctions not
strikes these powerful sanctions will
remain until Iran changes its behavior
CBS News has learned that senator Lee
was just one of the lawmakers who were
not able to get in a question during
this briefing which lasted over an hour
but White House officials had assured
the lawmakers that they would be willing
to return to answer additional questions
Anthony Paula thank you
you